and mr. Cooper on your Twitter I noticed
that you have hashtag responsible tweets
and we've been talking with a lot of the
people here that when there is great
power there's also great responsibility
to have a message that's for the people
why do you advocate that what are some
of the things that you preach to people
that do have followings in terms of
being responsible I think I think there
is no power without responsibility and I
think all artists out ultimately you
could choose to be the Entertainer but
at one point our artists of the
conscience of society always and
therefore part of their body rebellious
that's part of their job to be the
conscience conscience always rebellious
against structure and all artists need
to carry that responsibility of being
the functions of the society and carry
responsibility you know not carelessly
you can't be careless
and mr. Rushdie is saying that the
banning of the film is like cultural
terrorism it's a cultural emergency that
we are not able to see the film in India
right now and there's a two-week ban or
however long they have what's your take
on that I think Salman is completely
right he said the right thing I think
that what what happens is fringe groups
come in and take over and the fear of
violence by these many groups often will
stop any kind of cultural identity of
the film or culture growth and I think
it's the state's responsibility not
responsibility to ban the films but to
ensure that there's no violence I mean
that's why we like to have an elected
government so I think that's really is
cultural terrorism is caused by the
inability of the state to stop violence
provoked by French thank you so much